is the founder and president of dream
Corp and he was the special advisor for
green jobs to the 44th President of the
United States Barack Obama and you can
see him on CNN he's the host of the
messy truth with Van Jones and you can
also see him on many of the shows on CNN
pleased to have here van Jones on the
show good to see you sir glad to be here
now you're here in Los Angeles you live
here but you're here especially to kick
off the we rise tour as a that is
beginning on this Wednesday at the
Hollywood Palladium for those who are
unfamiliar what is the we're on tour it
is just an attempt to get people out of
the grumpy Gus mode I mean the election
season had everybody mad and then
afterwards had some people were glad
some people were sad but everybody's
still grumpy and I just think that we've
got a great country we've got a bunch of
big problems to solve neither political
party is great neither political parties
as good as the people United States and
so we've got a bunch of celebrities
we've got some athletes we got a bunch
of surprises coming out I'm going to 14
cities you know I'm usually on TV yes
and that the thing about TV is everybody
can see you but you can't see anybody
you just see the people you're working
here great people you can't see the
people so we're going to fill up a bunch
of auditoriums and arenas and have a
real conversation people going to get a
chance to get together talk about what's
working which should be working people
like Russell Simmons coming out on
Wednesday Nick Cannon coming out on
Wednesday local artists coming out on
Wednesday and that starts a whole
nationwide tour call we want so when you
say a conversation so people just be
able to grab a microphone and ask you
questions or what what what how does a
content form a coupling is going to
happen mainly you're going to be hearing
from some of these people who you may
use to you know you think about a
Russell Simmons you know he cares about
stuff but you also know he's a big
entrepreneur it's gonna be talking about
stuff that he cares about some of the
other people are going to be coming
talking about stuff that they care about
we're going to get into how do you rise
when you have a personal setback when
you have a political setback when you
have a community setback how do you turn
a breakdown into a breakthrough that's
the number the number one theme that
helps everybody done if you're
Republican Democrat doesn't matter how
do you turn a breakdown into a
breakthrough but we also going to have
local activists local leaders local
artists in that place
the stage people can turn in questions
it's going to be a situation when people
leave I guarantee you no matter what you
were thinking before you walked in
you're going to walk out with better
ideas more solutions more energy more
connections more contact than you had
when you walked in there and that's what
we need right now if you're waiting for
the politicians to save you you're gonna
wait for a long time we the people gotta
get together okay both parties of all
parties parties kind of suck you nobody
wants to admit this but these parties
are great and yet you got great people
and you know what's so terrible right
now you got people who won't even speak
to each other they grew up together
they're their family members they were
high school together
because of what somebody puts on their
Facebook page they know they they don't
just unfriend them in social reality
they unfriend them people are losing
friends and family members over politics
now these politicians are worth it let's
do something about these kids who need
mentorship let's do something about
these kids who are addicted let's do
something about these kids getting
caught up in the criminal justice system
the Republicans and Democrats
independent everybody else should be
focusing on the people who both parties
have let down and how we can help them
and get out of this nonsense we wouldn't
this food fight a glass or two long fan
Jones here on the Richardson show you're
doing this in conjunction with Roc
Nation jay-z yeah yeah and so jay jay is
jay-z and rock nation have gotten
considerably into athlete representation
in recent days and you mentioned that
some athletes are going to be showing up
on the on the we rise tour you've had
communication with Steph Curry
for instance and on various yeah items
of community interest right at the dream
core which is really the main
beneficiary this whole tour all 14
cities the ticket sales will go to
charity and the charity that they go to
primarily is the dream Corps in the
dream court has a lot on criminal
justice a lot on getting kids jobs and
technology with yes we Code which I
started with Prince the lady rockstar
but Steph Curry helped us on some
criminal justice stuff last year and so
did Alicia Keys listen a lot of people
look at the news every day whether
they're sports stars whether they're
other entertainers whether it's normal
people they say what can I do I don't
like what I'm seeing I got to wait for
years to vote no
you know you can go to love army org
right now sign up call out get plugged
in get revitalized meet some people you
hadn't met before and let's start
working together again and in terms of
athletes though I mean you you've seen
it many times anytime that I tweet about
something that is outside of the world
of sports I'm told to stick to sports
stick to football and then eventually
just stick it but they beat weeds get
smaller and smaller and a lot of
athletes don't want to say anything in
this day and age up do you think
athletes should be more vocal than they
of course on both sides on all issues
and I'll tell you why the number one
rare thing in the world right now it's
not it's not money I mean there's money
all over the place that I don't have
enough you don't have enough it's all
over the place it's time its attention
the richest people I know are still time
poor so if somebody has attention if
they're famous they have the most
valuable commodity in the world if you
can use that to make the world better
you should and part of the problem I see
now is people are saying I'm not going
to speak out here these great issues
that are going on bad things happening
that I'm not going to speak out because
I want to protect my paycheck that's
very inspiring sir we're going to put
that on your tombstone like said nothing
protect a paycheck are the folks that
aren't politicians on Capitol Hill do
enough on politicians and state houses
aren't politicians everywhere doing it
exactly when it comes down to it you are
making my point is that democracy is not
about the politicians democracy is about
the people and it doesn't matter who you
are just because you can throw a
football well doesn't mean you stop
being a citizen doesn't mean stop being
a human being that means stop being a
parent and all of us are supposed to
speak out democracy works when you have
the conversation going you know you take
you look at the really great ones the
Muhammad Ali's the Jim Browns you know
the people who in their time they
weren't just relevant on the field they
were relevant beyond the field as well
those the ones that we remember Van
Jones from CNN as well as the we rise
toward that begins in Los Angeles on
Wednesday going to San Francisco Denver
Atlanta Philly in New York just to name
a few cities what do you think of Colin
Kaepernick situation van because
you know there's an argument although
some people believe it's open-and-shut
in the favor of the fact that
Kaepernick's getting blackballed out of
the National Football League because of
his stances that he's taken publicly or
sitting whaling I think it's a very very
terrible thing if his teammates had come
forward and said look this guy we can't
deal with this guy we're trying to do
our push-ups he's talking about politics
we're trying to deal with try to get a
smoothy he's talking about what we can't
deal with this guy right all of his
teammate said he's an exemplary guy the
people who are dealing with him on a
daily basis it's not a distraction he's
an addition to what we're trying to do
and so what you're basically saying is
you want cowards
you don't want courageous people you
don't want people have an opinion
you want you want cowards who will run
the place how does that make America
better
I don't think makes America better at
all I think if somebody is able to get
out there and perform at the highest
levels and they come back and say I love
Donald Trump what difference does it
make they come back and they say I want
police brutality to stop who I love the
way i love the sharks i want i want to
kiss a shark whatever your thing is do
your thing because what young people
need to see if people who are excellent
and who are authentic people if you say
you got to be phony to make it the kids
of america noticed that and then you
have bigger problems and you just try to
solve based on one guy last one for you
because I know you're gonna you're gonna
a hold tour based off of the we rise
tour that you're that you're starting
you mentioned Prince's name yeah how did
you get to know him you know I run in my
mouth ten years ago in Oakland trying to
get kids jobs and kids standing on
street corners I said listen you guys I
don't want you in front of my house
you're getting on my nerves in front of
my house I want you on top of my house
putting up solar panels I started
getting young people jobs in the solar
industry Prince found out about it and
tried to send me money anonymously but I
don't take anonymous money so I'm
sending the check back he sends it I
finally his guy calls and says you got
to take this cheque I said I don't take
him out of his money who is it because I
can't tell ya I'm not taking he goes
listen I won't tell you the guy's name
but his favorite color is purple
haha guess what man now you got another
problem what's that I said now I'm not
gonna cash it I'm gonna frame it on
something problem as a present that was
so funny he called me and we were
together for almost 10 years no caring
yeah I mean this guy the most generous
guy in the world he put money into so
many causes but he never want anybody to
know so the day he died I went on TV and
I exposed all his secrets I said I got
big secret to expose this guy gave away
tens of millions of dollars
did you really tens of millions of
dollars o'clock that I know about and I
don't know
you know everything about but I can
attest to tens of millions and he never
wanted any credit for it and people got
mad well why are you revealing it now I
said he didn't want me to talk about it
you two stayed here so you've gone now
somebody's got to tell the truth Prince
Rogers Nelson won the biggest
philanthropists one of the best people
in the world and an artistic genius hmm
van thanks for coming in appreciate it
yeah you know I mean back yeah any time
it's good I want like we got to do it
listen there's no just difference as far
as I'm concerned
excellence is excellence whether its its
commentary whether it's sports politics
entertainment spirituality whatever it
is good people should be talking more
we've fragmented so much now that you
can know everything about sports you
know nothing about politics or vice
versa doesn't work let's say together
well I'd love to absolutely and good
luck with the with the we rise tour love
army torch I got love army dot org org
to see if the we rise tour is coming to
your town back in sixty Seconds with
your phone calls animal the Rich Eisen
shown weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like some of that get some more
of that on the Rich Eisen shell app
follow all the information you see right
here on the Rich Eisen show